there's more bad news for southern  california theme parks  some counties are still at a high risk  level of cobig 19 spread  so disney six flags and other parks will  remain closed  there will be businesses that will be  lost forever we could see hotels taken  over by banks  and then for families my heart breaks  for them knowing that they are  struggling to pay rent  they are struggling to put food on the  table  now there is no timetable for a  reopening but some officials say the  best case scenario  could be theme parks open next spring  some smaller parks will be allowed to  reopen but only with those outdoor  attractions and of course at a limited  capacity  now part of a statement from the  president of disneyland resorts reads  we have proven that we can responsibly  reopen with science-based health and  safety protocols  nevertheless the state of california  continues to ignore this fact  instead mandating arbitrary guidelines  that it knows  are unworkable end quote